look at that wow
welcome to pill country
cool
okay
should we do uh some questions thank you
my ex took so many plan b's we called
her pill country all right
here we go
[Music]
derek robidu robideaux robidu oh that's
a good name
robadoo the guy who's always in trouble
yeah damn you robadoo get in here
uh i have a p for you when a youtube
video or podcast has a 15 second clip at
the beginning showing the funniest part
totally gives it away and ruins the
punchline
yeah i agree with this but you know what
blame the algorithm dude
it all comes back to that dumb out you
know because i've had young people cut
videos from me and do that for me and
i'm like what the hell is this no like
it does well and i'm just like yeah but
it ruins
it ruins the thing i know it's all like
i think when they see something extreme
happen they're like i should stick
around exactly yeah it's all to grab you
and hold you in but it does [ __ ] up the
ending they do this with netflix too
they'll play like you you know you you
leave it on the the cursor on one video
and they'll just play half of it and
you're like
don't give anything away
yeah i hate when trailers give away too
much of a movie too i hate when it's
like because sometimes movie trailers
like our attention span has gotten
shorter everything's gotten shorter and
for some reason movie trailers seem
longer than ever so long isn't that
weird yeah where it's like i don't need
a three-minute movie trailer no minute
and a half in and out yeah even movies
are like three hours two hour and 58
minutes i'm like
i when what what what are we doing here
are we are we 80d are we not 80d which
one is it but then the weird thing is
like for whatever reason movies i guess
because it's like all about how it's
supposed to be consumed right because tv
shows
10 episodes what is that like you know
10 hours in hours right and then we're
mad that a movie is three hours it's
true but i guess it's the control aspect
you can get up you can turn it off you
can walk around you can eat whatever it
is isn't that weird like shows now we
just assume they're gonna have fat on
them
so it's like it used to be commercials
you'd get up and do [ __ ] now you're like
well this is a slow scene i'll get up
and do that's true
interesting especially these netflix doc
things these bio
series they add so much we could have
knocked this out one app bad i couldn't
do bad vegan no i couldn't take it
they're repeating the same [ __ ] peters
you shake your head too yeah it's so
it's it was crazy right also who are
these women who are these women i'm like
i've been dumped for such misdemeanor
[ __ ] right and then these women are
dating guys who are like losers and
they're like can i borrow 120 grand and
they're like sure i know right
the what did you finish bad vegan
no i i heard what i read what happened
though
isn't that crazy isn't that crazy that
they're still together
it's funny when i was first watching it
i was like she's pretty hot maybe alec
baldwin yeah like i was like man maybe
that would have been like a good and
then after a while you're like oh she's
crazy yeah yeah yeah i think so maybe
she would have been great for alec
baldwin nah maybe they would have worked
together
well he'll take a shot
that's the new true crime he kills her
and he's like doug i didn't pull the
trigger i didn't pull it